juan orlando hernández está un paso más
cerca de la extradición a eeuu un juez
de tegucigalpa autorizó la extradición
del ex mandatario quien es solicitado
por narcotráfico corrupción y tráfico de
armas de fuego por una corte de nueva
york los abogados defensores tienen tres
días para preparar una apelación está
claro de lo que resulta es una clara
violación a la soberanía de una clara
violación a los derechos fundamentales
de la persona que se ordena la
extradición y en su momento a partir de
ahora estas decisiones del poder
judicial generan la respuesta
responsabilidad internacional del estado
de honduras en el marco de los derechos
humanos juan orlando hernández está
detenido desde el 15 de febrero y
continuará bajo arresto en una
instalación militar mientras la corte
suprema decide sobre el recurso de
apelación
eeuu alega que hernández formaba parte
de una operación para enviar a la unión
americana toneladas de cocaína
provenientes de colombia y venezuela
además se le acusa de aceptar millones
de dólares en su hornos para y pedir que
narcotraficantes fueran investigados y
llevados a juicio en 2021 una corte de
nueva york condenó al hermano de
hernández toni a cadena perpetua por
narcotráfico